fellow
made a video of my science series
and he addressed each one of the videos
each one of the points
and i commend him for that he uh went in
there and analyzed each point from his
point of view obviously right and i
think more people should be doing that
uh not necessarily with me but with
their teachers i mean if you have
instructors or teachers in college or
school or high school or whatever i
think you should put them on the spot
see if how much they know if they can
defend their positions okay and that's i
think uh good for morale in science
you need that okay anyways uh he uh
addressed uh almost every point
i think he addressed them all in fact
and
one of the issues there is that you know
he said that he's not a scientist or
that he's not a physicist okay and we
don't hold that against him here i mean
under no circumstance we don't care he's
got a phd or he's just got a high school
we don't care okay uh we're going to
look at his arguments okay that's
important here at least
and so we don't care if he's got a nobel
prize or he just came out of school uh
that's one issue the other one is that
you know he since he addressed each one
of the issues
uh that i raised in my videos uh you
know there's no way i can have one
lecture with all that
you know to address each one of those
points so i'm going to be doing that
over the next few weeks i was going to
be addressing those same topics in one
way or another in the next few weeks
anyways because that's why i was making
the science series okay so in a way it's
it comes in very handy to use his video
uh as a uh you know as a guide and one
of the issues there is that you know
this fellow represents as far as i'm
concerned i mean i've been in this for
25 years now and i've heard it all okay
and i can tell you one thing this fellow
has the same idea that 99 of the people
out there have
uh and what i call misconceptions of
science misconceptions of physics and
those i want to address but it's good
because he's the typical case
for what people usually think out there
what people say out there so he's he's a
perfect case for this
anyways
the issues i'll be addressing in the
coming weeks okay i want you to put it
in the right context so that you're
aware those who want to follow the
series okay
and i'm going to be looking at what is
science about what is physics about okay
i'm going to compare the scientific
method versus what i call the
mathematical method okay what's the
mathematical mathematical method it's
what we have today and that we've had
now for 400 years okay that's
essentially what i'm going to call the
mathematical method why do i call it
mathematical because they do everything
by magic
black magic
uh what is black magic uh when you move
concepts around you transfer energy you
wave the wave you vibrate the field
and there are no such physical objects
in physics okay so we're going to
distinguish objects from concepts as you
can see there at the bottom we need to
know what a difference is between an
object and a concept
and
that's 90 of the problem there as i like
to say
the definition of the word object
destroys all religions
and i'm going to look at explain versus
describe another big major problem
people don't understand the difference
between an explanation and a description
a lot of people think that an
explanation is just a bunch of
descriptions a series of descriptions
okay big difference between an
explanation of this description but few
people can tell them apart and so we
need to clarify that one uh theory
versus hypothesis big issue there also
uh people don't understand the
difference uh the establishment has
brainwashed everyone to think that a
hypothesis is an unproven theory and a
tentative
explanation no that's not what a
hypothesis is at all okay we're gonna
address that and uh then we're gonna
look at rational versus irrational
because uh people everybody wants to
think of themselves as rational
and we're going to show that now we
define what rational is what irrational
is and then whoever meets those criteria
is either rational or irrational okay so
we go by definitions
and uh so what are we going to be
addressing specifically well here you
have it these are the invisible
intangible mechanisms objects uh things
out there that the mathematical
establishment has never been able to
address never been able to answer
okay and so they
invoke gravity you know nobody can
understand in mathematical physics right
nobody can understand what causes
gravity how it's caused how mother
nature does it they can tell you how it
does how it moves like you know the
acceleration that sort of thing but they
can't tell you the cause how does mother
nature perform this magic trick that's
what they cannot explain
uh so the mechanisms that's what we're
looking at magnetism how does a magnet
attract another they don't have an
explanation for that people think they
have but again they just they confuse
description with explanation and
electricity
they have no idea how electricity works
mainly because they don't know what the
an atom looks like which is the next one
there atomic architecture behavior
they have this little bead rolling
around the nucleus and the only answer
they have to give there is
why doesn't the electron fly out of the
atom
like why does the earth fly out of the
solar system same thing here if the
electron is a little beat that goes
around or is somewhere around the proton
the question is why does it
spontaneously fly away or fall into the
nucleus and if you cannot explain that
you do not have an explanation for
electricity because electricity today is
defined as the flow of electron beads so
we have a problem with electricity if
the atom that they're basing it on is
bunk okay and then light of course uh
you know you need to understand
uh
what physical entity mediates light
and why are these important visible and
intangible because we we figured out
pretty much you know all the visible
stuff you ask a kid
you know how did the cart
move from a to b
okay
and he says very simple i attached the
car to a horse
and a horse pulled it and that's how it
went from a to b
and we all look at that
if he shows us a movie of that right or
even with his explanation and we all
understand it
we understand it why because we see all
the objects
okay we see everything there in front of
us we see the cart we see the rains we
see the uh horse and we see it moving we
see the movie of that and we all
understand it just by looking you don't
need to go to the university you need
you do not need to understand
mathematics
all you need to understand is how that
cart moved from a to b and a
ten-year-old can tell you that
okay and so what's the issue the issue
is that
you know all these invisible intangible
entities what's the problem or
mechanisms or phenomena the problem
there is you cannot see the mediator
that's the that's the whole problem
you know here you have the pen okay we
let go of it it falls to the floor right
and you don't see anything here you
don't see anything here you can't touch
anything here or there
so people conclude that there's nothing
there
gravity is done by magic
and we're going to say the argument is
going to be that there is something
there
you just can't see it or touch it but
there is something there
that is in contact with the skin of the
pen
and people say bill you're crazy
what do you mean i don't see anything i
don't touch it yet because you're using
c touch
the definition of the word object that
which has shape
so what's there what's here or here
has shape
but you can't see or touch it
and you say what kind of shape does it
have i can't see or touch it well shape
is unrelated to see and touch that's the
issue anyways i'm going to get into that
later on in
in the coming weeks but the point here
is and
you if you're going to be doing
gravity if you're going to be doing
light if you're going to be doing
electricity magnetism without an a
mediator
you're using black magic
and that's what mathematical physics has
that's why we call it mathematical
physics they do it with black magic they
do it with concepts not with objects
okay so that's the issue
okay so um
here we have a
rundown of what mathematical method is
which is the one that i'm going to be
addressing attacking okay analyzing okay
and essentially
the big problem is that this is not a
scientific method what this is is just a
method of research and persuasion
and to give people something to do you
know to study as they call it and
studying is not science science is
explaining this tell me something that
came out of all that work if nothing
comes out of that work you're not doing
science and so what these people do is
just uh you know the so-called method
that we inherited from the 17th century
so-called scientific that's with
quotations right scientific revolution
is uh is this you know it consists of um
you observe something or someone
observes something right uh you give it
a tentative explanation known as a
hypothesis
and that's really not true because uh
mathematical physics doesn't rely on
explanations at all as i showed in other
videos you know you have these people
saying that science doesn't explain
meaning mathematics doesn't explain
mathematics describes so no they don't
do explanation but they call them
explanations because again people think
that explanations are just a bunch of a
series of descriptions okay but that's
what they call a hypothesis a tentative
explanation okay uh then they do a
prediction they say okay let me figure
out and see if i understood if my theory
or my tentative theory is correct and
i'm gonna make a prediction to see if
that's what happens when i put it under
certain conditions and then you do an
experiment meaning you're gonna do some
measurement you describe it
mathematically after you take some data
and some numbers there and then you
describe it mathematically you know
perhaps with an equation so that's just
a description so far you haven't
explained anything okay uh
they do
they invent technology and they think
that technology is proof of
uh theories
you'll hear a lot of people out there
just parrot and say it over and over
again because they never even thought
what they're saying about what they're
saying and they say gps
proves that general relativity is
correct and computers prove that quantum
mechanics is correct because you
wouldn't have a computer it wouldn't
work if it weren't for quantum mechanics
and blah blah blah blah blah blah
and again it shows the irrationality of
all these people okay the gps proved
that time is a physical object that you
can warp that you can bend like a banana
does a computer prove that a particle
can be at two places at once
because those are the explanations they
give you
and you say well if that weren't true
the computer wouldn't work
the computer works because of trial and
error that's how technology is made or
like mr uh thomas edison said you know i
haven't failed
i just found ten thousand ways that
don't work he just tried one thing after
another until he got it right did edison
need to know what a field is or what
electricity is
obviously not in the 19th century all he
did was try things until he got it right
that's how technology works has nothing
at all to do with the explanation the
theory of how it works out there in the
world of invisible world of mother
nature father universe or whatever okay
so this is the issue and uh so people
say they think that technology has
something to do with science it does not
technology is uh
producing a gadget by trial and error
science is explaining
you know how the universe works how
gravity works how electricity or
magnetism works that's what science is
that's what
physics is
then what they do is they go around
persuading people okay to convince them
to give them a prize or you know to
grant them something maybe money or a
good position somewhere and um
someone you know they vote for it uh
they say well if you got 50 plus one
then it becomes truth becomes a theory
okay and from theory goes to proof and
truth and fact that's the way they work
in mathematics and uh those who are on
the losing end they say oh i'm going to
verify his his reading i'm going to
verify his experiment see if it's what
he collected all that information is
correct and so they do a verification
what is called falsification falsifying
okay uh
austrian fellow there who came up with
all that nonsense and they finally win
an award and uh you know medals and so
on so that they uh have authority you
know you win a noble then you can trash
anyone on earth because you know who are
you
i've got a noble what do you have you
know
it's that kind of thing
okay um
and so here uh you see the the what we
propose in exchange we're saying this is
the rational scientific method this is
what science really is
it's a rational explanations and we
that's why we're going to have to work
on the word rational and the word
explanation okay those two words we need
to understand very well in order to
understand what science is but the
scientific method is a way of explaining
to someone else a mechanism in the case
of physics obviously we do physics here
okay and what is a hypothesis nothing to
do with a theory nothing to do with an
explanation hypothesis are the objects
the definitions and the initial scene
with which you start your theory you
have to start the movie of your theory
your explanation somewhere okay and this
is essentially the
the objects are you know what objects
are you gonna use in your theory what
definitions are you gonna use are they
solid you know are they irrational et
cetera and then you know
what is known as a statement of the
facts you have to base your theory on
the initial scenes you know if your uh
theory your explanation doesn't follow
from the initial scenes then you have an
irrationality you know i mean
hopefully the theory follows from your
initial assumptions and then the theory
is the mechanisms and the causes okay
what caused something to happen what is
the mechanism that mother nature uses
out there and again we're looking at the
invisible stuff because all the visible
stuff we've already figured out what we
haven't figured out or the
mathematicians haven't figured out are
the invisible stuff that's what we're
going to be looking at okay and then
where yeah we have the coral areas at
the end uh i'm not going to go over that
too much okay
okay so what does this fellow say well
he uh he
made a couple statements from the start
in his video and it just blew me away
i'm saying my god how can we you know uh
be so different you know and this is
what he said okay this is how he starts
his presentation give me a second here
and i'll get it started all right pay
attention please okay here it goes
the issue and argument raised in this
rejoinder is
the mathematical method has done well
over the last 400 years since the
mathematics revolution
the scientific method has worked pretty
well so far since its inception we've
managed to find out quite a bit about
the universe especially over the last
couple hundred years
okay
now when i heard that
i didn't need to go any further because
he already set a mouthful there first
thing thought that came to mind is you
know i'm from planet earth
what planet are you from
please take me to your leader
now maybe i'm in the wrong planet i
don't know it could be that i'm in the
wrong planet and i need to find out
maybe i went to the land of the klingons
maybe i went uh a time travel to the
future maybe to kill my granddaughter
before she comes back to the past he
kills me first you know and with general
relativity you never know you know uh so
the question is which one of us is on
the right planet uh
have we um
had success with science has it gotten
better over time especially in the last
200 years
well i see it exactly in reverse
i'm saying that we have made no progress
in the last 2 500 years since the days
of the greek at least right
and in the last 200 years more like 150
years last 150 years we went backwards
we got we got worse we have more and
more irrational explanations for common
phenomena we don't have rational
explanations and so this fellow says we
make progress i'm saying we have not
made progress one of them one of us is
on the wrong planet okay it could be me
yeah that's what we're gonna find out
okay so uh let me show you some
irrationalities that i just kind of
brainstormed uh
so as to guide today's lecture okay uh
that just can't pop into my head uh some
of them have to do with what i've been
covering in the last couple weeks okay
so uh those who stuck around you'll
you'll realize you'll you'll see what
i'm talking about here you know i'm
covering some of the old ground and
serves as a
summary for the month of march anyways
and here's a all the irrationalities
that are rampant in mathematical physics
now this this is a very small list i
could tell you i could go on and on and
on and on i got a list this long okay
but um
this is a good place to start i mean
this fella says that we have rational
explanations i guess he's thinking about
or that science is doing fine especially
the last 200 years and i'm saying you
know right now we have something called
dark matter out there dark energy
and those are two irrationalities
complete irrational nonsense poppycock
okay and here let me show you an example
of that here's a the balloon analogy
that i covered a couple weeks ago again
okay and dark matter is on the inside
pulling the universe inwards and we have
the dark energy you know kind of like
the anti-gravity pushing the space
outwards okay and all the galaxies are
really stuck to the end to the surface
of the balloon so as the balloon grows
the theory is that all the galaxies fly
apart and that's why the universe is
flying apart according to mathematical
physics right before our very eyes and
the first question that a irrational
individual asks is what's the what's the
white stuff that's what we want to
understand
and that's an answer you won't find and
they won't give you and they say look
it's an unscientific question you cannot
ask you know what is uh
what is the white uh stuff out there and
uh you know it's like asking they say
it's like asking what's north of the
north pole
well you know north of the north pole
you have polaris uh there's a star there
and beyond that you have galaxies and
stars and asteroids and what have you
you know so so there is stuff north of
the north pole so that's a terrible
analogy or a terrible answer who someone
invented in everyone else's parents
without even thinking what they're
saying and the question here is that
that white stuff gives um
contour to that balloon which is space
the balloon is space so they're treating
space as a physical object because again
an object is that which has shape and
what we're staring at is that which has
shape
so whenever you have shape you have to
have something giving it contour you
have to answer what is the white stuff
and it turns out that that little um
white stuff is the one they can't answer
just by sheer coincidence okay and yeah
that that is suspicious you know they
elude the question that we want answered
okay
and here you have um
another version of what dark matter is i
covered that again a couple weeks ago
but let's go over real quickly over it
uh you see a couple galaxies on your
right side there one on top one on the
bottom and what we show there is one
star which has a certain radius from the
center of the galaxy and the other one
has a longer radius in other words it's
farther out
and what the mathematicians the
astronomers out there
eventually concluded is that the ones on
the outside travel at the same speed or
faster than the ones on the inside and
that's counter-intuitive because you
know that would be like pluto traveling
faster than mercury around the sun
that's essentially what you're staring
at there
and so how do they come up with the dark
matter which is that the halo that you
see around each galaxy okay i made it
visible okay and and you know i direct
your attention to the bottom of the
bottom left of the screen area where you
see that little equation now you don't
have to have any math to understand what
i'm going to because i just i'm looking
at this from a conceptual point of view
you have that little v which is velocity
we don't care about the square because
again we're looking at it conceptually
and you see the big r which is uh the
radius and the issue is as r gets bigger
and bigger and bigger okay the radius uh
gets bigger and bigger in the galaxy in
other words the star is farther and
farther away from the center of the
galaxy the little v there the one with
velocity squared the little v is getting
bigger and you say how can that be it's
totally contrary to what the equation
tells you it should be the other way
around if r goes big then the v should
go
smaller
and what they've done is to compensate
for that they invented this variable
called dark matter
dark matter is just a bunch of mass
artificial mass that they put in the
equation to compensate actually over
compensate
to make sure that the velocity matches
what they see what the astronomers see
out there in the night sky that's the
issue okay so dark matter is a variable
and they turn this variable into a
physical object into particles
okay and now they're searching for them
and they're saying well what else could
it be
and yes we have a different explanation
for that you know i've talked about that
in the past several times so i'm not
going to cover it here but the point is
these people have a variable which they
turned into particles
mass you know which they needed to
compensate for the extra radius so that
the velocity matches what the
astronomers see out there
so it's a mathematical contraption
nothing but but since they can't think
of any other mechanism they say we
proved it there is
dark matter out there
and that's the majority of the
mathematicians there are others who
go with mond you know modified newtonian
and a couple other people are searching
for other intermediaries
between one and the other but
essentially they're looking for mass
they say the only way we can explain
that is with mass
and it turns out you know dark matter
according to our theory has nothing at
all to do with mass okay nothing okay so
uh
that's uh dark matter and dark energy uh
black hole i mean how irrational can you
get other than the black hole this
person says we've done a lot of progress
in the last 200 years what we invented
in the last 200 years at least 150 years
since einstein uh well einstein never
believed in black holes but i mean you
know you had all these other people who
took einstein's equations they turned
them into a black hole and today we have
this monster called black hole and it's
an irrational entity only
dum-dums you know believe in black holes
and you say why is it an irrational
entity well very simple i mean
it's a no-brainer okay there is no such
thing as a black hole because a black
hole is zero dimensional
zero size
and has no matter in it
and mass is the quantity of matter if i
remember correctly from high school
a long time ago okay so give me a second
here
it's the quantity of matter a measure of
a quantity of matter of course and if
it's got no matter it's got no mass
and so let's see zero dimensional
no volume no size
no mass no matter
looks like you're talking about nothing
and they say this nothing called a black
hole moves stars around and sucks the
skin of you know their gaseous skin from
the star
so yeah we have an irrationality and
these people just oh they proved that
they even took a picture of it
[Laughter]
okay so uh we got a problem because
these people don't understand that a
black hole is zero dimensional
no size no nothing
they don't understand that and they said
bill you're crazy what do you mean it's
no sign i mean i have several people who
told me that they said you know
no one says that a black hole has zero
size and uh
no no volume no dimensions no matter
meaning no mass where did you get this
bill
okay so let's put evidence proof right
that's what these people believe in
right authority above all authority i
mean some of you know a guy named
stephen hawking he was a british uh
mathematician mathematical physicist
died a few years ago
and uh he wrote a book a famous book
called a brief history of time
and you know some of you might be aware
of that book i guess if you've been in
the industry of physics right you should
know something about stephen hawking
this is what hawking has to say that's
not me okay this is you can check it out
for yourself verified on your own you
don't have to trust my word here okay
and here it is okay this is what good
old um stevie says okay he's talking
about chandrasekhar
who worked for arthur eddington and got
a nobel prize and so he's explaining how
chandrasekhar indian fellow uh won his
nobel prize and he wanted for proving
proving
with math mathematics right doing
mathematics uh equations that can sign a
thing right proving that a black hole is
zero dimensional here it is calculated
that that a cold star more than about
one and a half times mass of the sun
would not be able to support itself
against its own gravity when it
collapsed to infinite density infinite
density ring a bell
eddington was shocked by that
implication and he refused to believe
chandrasekhar's results eddington
thought it was simply not possible that
what
that a star could collapse to a point
meaning what did einstein say einstein
himself wrote a paper in which he
claimed that stars would not shrink to
zero
size
let me say that again you probably
didn't hear it zero size that's not me
saying it that's stevie there okay
however he was awarded the nobel prize
in 1983 for his early work on limiting
massive cold stars chandrasekhar had
shown that the exclusion principle right
quantum mechanics could not halt the
collapse of a star more massive than the
chandrasekhar limit zero size you say
well must have been a typo okay so let's
go to his other
part of the
book his book
says the following as penrose showed
penrose you know
also who just won the nobel prize a
couple i think last year showed that a
star collapsing under its own gravity is
trapped in a region whose surface
eventually shrinks to
zero size so we have all these people
proving zero size
uh black holes singularities okay
and since the surface of the region
shrinks to zero so too must its volume
all the matter in the star will be
compressed into a region of zero volume
is anybody hearing me uh i'm talking
about zeros here okay zero size zero
volume in other words one has a
singularity contained within a region of
space time known as a black hole
okay now uh this is not me i didn't
invent this okay you can find it in the
book i put the pages there so you can
check it out on your own because a lot
of people say bill you're crazy what are
you talking about zero size yeah zero
size black hole is zero size why would
why would a black hole a star right
that's collapsing on it because of its
own gravity why would it stop that you
know greater than zero what would be the
mechanism of stopping right there so
that you can say well there's still
something there a lot of mass compressed
into a little tiny thing
no it's not infinitesimal it's a zero
okay let's make sure we understand it
black hole is zero said there is no such
thing as a black hole okay and you say
well bill that's only one source okay
let's put another one just to make sure
that we have all the evidence on the
table let's follow his uh fellow over
there in cambridge and cambridge
university press published his book he
was a professor for several years i
think he still is on solving the
equation with a particular value rho of
central density you will get a model of
a star with mass m and radius r okay
plot r as a function of m and show that
r
falls to zero radius falls to zero zero
radius okay i hope you understand when m
is equal to chandrasekhar mass
if you can do all these then you have
repeated the calculation for which
chandrasekhar won the nobel prize
i hope you understood some of that you
know we're talking about zero zero zero
zero there's nothing there and let me
rub it in just while we're at it okay
here we have two fellows professor cole
milner university of maryland and
professor david harrison from the
university of toronto black holes are
the most exotic objects in the universe
a black hole is a region of space the
matter that forms a black hole is
crushed out of existence there is
nothing there
okay i hope uh that struck a bell
somewhere okay what does harrison say an
object whose gravitational pressure is
so intense that the matter of the object
is crushed out of
existence okay so we have no matter okay
and we have no uh size no volume
no dimensions
okay so the question is um
what do we have
what are we talking about you know
what's left and so here it is as far as
i know menace is a measure of quantity
of matter or you need something related
to matter that have mass
i think so okay well here we have it
okay we have all these folks the
dictionary the wikipedia all they say
all of them say the same thing mass is a
measure how much matter an object
contains turns out a black hole uh
crushes all matter out of existence okay
and so if mass is the quantity of matter
and the black hole crushes it matter all
out of existence we have no mass
whatsoever according to the definitions
of mathematical physics
so so far we have absolutely nothing in
front of us
okay
so no there is no such thing as a black
hole because a black hole by definition
is nothing
they define nothing
and then they took a picture of it and
they showed it to the world and they
showed a drain there with water going
around they said well the black hole is
is you can't see it there is is that a
black hole the picture you took no
that's matter rushing into a black hole
so where's the black hole what's the
zero dimensional singularity that has no
size that's in the center of that
okay
so that's how they sell these things and
people just buy it because they don't
understand anything they don't question
anything coming from the mathematical
establishment okay how about uh big bang
there we have uh next one down on the
list uh here we have big bang okay and i
showed this the other day okay our
universe according to mathematics space
time and matter are all in there so we
have space time and matter inside that
uh tilted glass that's pouring beer out
makes me thirsty okay anyways uh so we
had uh all these years we have uh
this thing it's been around for almost
14 billion years okay it's called the uh
space time the the blocked universe
whatever and the question is how did
this start
how did the first bit of matter start
and the way they calculated or the way
they figured this theory out is they
said look we figured out in the 1930s
1929 1930s that all galaxies are
expanding are flying away from each
other okay so the world is exploding
they say ah we got it we understand this
what's happened is yesterday we're
closer together and even before
yesterday they were even closer together
so if you take run the movie backwards
what you have is all matter condensing
into a little point a singularity and
you say well where did the singularity
come from i mean can you tell me that
and they say well no that's unscientific
to ask that question we don't know see
the theory stops at frame number two of
the film and i showed
the other day here it is that's uh
that's the movie of the big bang you
know it starts at frame number two it
doesn't go to frame number one where the
singularity is created they say we don't
know what happened there we can't
explain it it's unscientific because we
have no way of proving uh blah blah blah
blah blah and essentially what they're
saying is we cannot explain the
mechanism of how something comes
into existence from nothing that's
essentially the problem
and that's when the religious folk you
know they look at them and say ah they
smirk and they say ah you just don't
want to say that it's god who made all
this stuff right that's all your problem
and yeah this is this is the issue in in
that sense i gotta side with the
religious folk the traditional religion
uh because they've got the right idea
you know why did you stop frame number
two and say well we started the
singularity
well how convenient i mean when did you
start at you know before the singularity
what happened well it's another answer
they give you is like i said you know
when i analyzed uh some of the religious
folks like saint augustine and saint
anselm and
st thomas aquinas you know and they all
had this idea that god is outside of
time he got made time you know he made
all the time he could
and so he made time so he's outside of
time and these people are more or less
saying the same thing that time began
with the singularity
and so the religious folks americans say
we know what you're trying to say you're
trying to avoid god all you atheists
right
yeah they're right they're totally right
that's that's the issue they're trying
to avoid you know
god god made the singularity and the
question is um you know they say well we
don't need god and that's fine you don't
need god but then you have to have an
explanation of how the singularity came
to be
you can't avoid that you can't sidestep
that question by sidestepping it ruins
your entire theory your theory is bunk
you cannot say the galaxy going back and
back and back until we reach frame
number two if you can't take it to frame
number one you don't have a rational
theory because that's the issue the
issue is how did something come in from
nothing can you explain that
and they do have i don't know if you can
call it an explanation
uh an excuse that's probably a little
better and here it is okay this is what
it looks like and it's uh
it's a um
what's my call it's uh someone asked the
question cora and uh phd answered the
question and it's how this question was
answered that's important okay and which
answers the question of how the universe
came to be how matter came in to be okay
and here it is it says is it true that
in quantum mechanics particles can
appear and disappear seemingly from
nowhere or without a cause
and a phd this is a phd okay he answers
qm obeys physical law not magic oh okay
good thank god and says yes the way
things behave at the quantum level is
often weird and very non-intuitive
bad way to start a presentation he's
going to say that it's counter intuitive
okay i guess uh we're heading into
irrationality here
and you and yes during high energy
collisions all sorts of particles can
appear disappear out of the vacuum that
we're not even there to begin with
okay sounds like magic but again all
this goes according to well-established
theory quantum field theory not magic
[Laughter]
so uh that's just a statement these
people are doing magic and saying oh no
ours is not magic magic was what the
traditional religions did we don't do
magic
and so you see where the problem is
these people are doing magic they're
saying it's science
and so yeah this fellow um he was
educated with all this stuff you know
time dilation some of the others there
i'm not going to go over all those but
he was educated with all this stuff
or read about him i guess
and um he just accepted it at face value
on the basis of authority
you know the mathematical physicists the
scientists
they fit into the world and he said well
they can't all be wrong i mean the guys
in cambridge the the ones in uh harvard
the ones in caltech the chinese the
russians all these people are wrong bill
they're not wrong they're all irrational
because they don't care about mechanisms
that's why they're irrational they give
you a bogus physical interpretation
saying well we moved the energy in this
direction we moved the field over there
and then the mass was kicked out in that
other direction so they talk about all
these concepts and people say whoa
that's over my head i guess you know
because all you mathematicians know all
those equations and you talk about mass
and all the stuff we don't understand so
you must be right
and essentially it amounts to what
happened in the middle ages where the
only person in the village who could
read was the priest and so he would tell
them what the bible said and everybody
else had just to accept whether they
liked what they were hearing or not they
had to accept it because the only guy
could read was the priest and we have
these priests the modern day priests are
the mathematicians you know uh they've
been handed this um
the mathematical world and people say
well i don't understand all that stuff
so i'm just going to rely on what he
says and when all the mathematicians say
we all agree you know space-time black
holes uh dark matter particle at two
places at one people say well it must be
true because they can't all be wrong
so it's an issue of authority nothing
but okay
if they're all irrational they're all
flat earthers we're all screwed